-Of course, Thanksgiving
isn't just about food.
It's all about posting pictures
of your food on social media.
But there are some important
things to know
about posting
your Thanksgiving plate.
So I wrote a tiny song about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ PSA, Thanksgiving food doesn't
photograph too good ♪
♪ It just looks like
a big old pile of beige ♪
♪ I'm sure your dinner
tasted great ♪
♪ But that tan rainbow on
your plate's not showing up on ♪
♪ No one's "For You" page ♪
♪ Mystery scoops of
brown and white ♪
♪ Gravy filmed by candlelight
ain't the look ♪
♪ That home cooking deserves ♪
♪ Hashtag dinner,
hashtag snacky ♪
♪ All looks like you serve
wet khakis ♪
♪ Bowls of soggy burlap
for dessert ♪
♪ So PSA, Thanksgiving food
doesn't photograph too good ♪
♪ In worst-case scenarios
looks gross ♪
♪ Just take a picture with your
fam or your friends together ♪
♪ Not of ham ♪
♪ That's why your mom told you
to wear nice clothes ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.